[Music]
it's a beautiful day to be alive it's
Tuesday June 13th slinging dick and
given our bubblegum I'm get ready I got
the Marc Maron cup I got the coffee
we got the refre dent we got the [ __ ]
nicotine gum I think I need some [ __ ]
3d glasses already ensue
[ __ ] it we're up listen I do the [ __ ]
first joined the day with you guys at
9:00 but before 9:00 we have a pre
[ __ ] joint it starts about 6:00 a.m.
I've been right before an hour already
and I'm ready to [ __ ] go you
understand me why not join my family in
an early early early morning spark
that's how we do it here 6:00 a.m. I got
the robot on all my [ __ ] bout me like
you have to know what a [ __ ] hard-on
it's a beautiful day to be alive you're
up you're much beaten
your eyeballs are up my balls are in
shape I already provides meaning those
[ __ ] I've been blanking them
for an hour and they're ready for
[ __ ] me for world today but Joey
enough with the chitter chatter let's do
this ball I haven't go back in the
[ __ ] office and type letters for
three hours like I said I got your
tremendous [ __ ] Louise right now as
we speak I got some weed cultivated the
cards been in there since yesterday I
haven't even open the windows from them
I spell this [ __ ] up and get the
base daughter right some people could
jump in Jack some people to kale shakes
they could all suck my dick we got a
live large we gotta go deep we gotta
think outside the box
wisdom may know wisdom discernment
there's not even another chitty-chat
it's just two fat [ __ ] smoking I got
the robot people walking their dogs the
smell of this [ __ ] reefer go home what
is going on in America
you know what's going on uncle Joey
that's cool
I'm [ __ ] creepin while you're sleeping
[ __ ]
I'm sneaking up at new [ __ ] rooster
at 6:00 a.m. say you ever sneak up on a
rooster snack and wake up God suckle
ain't no cop a total do here today Uncle
Joe is the only cop in [ __ ] town
tremendous
I have a smoke pot my rope and pública a
long [ __ ] time I'm happy you guys are
up get ready to salute the flag with
your [ __ ] hands on your boss and
getting ready to be a [ __ ] American
no peers today no rule to free no
nothing get out there smoke some reefer
right you goats say a prayer for the man
upstairs cuz he's there and get out
there
as it as good as it gets in America to
my cousins in Cuba drinkin [ __ ] fresh
coffee right now smoke in the air above
that [ __ ] no net wakin I'm hungry
looking around thinking how they got a
split egg six [ __ ] ways you don't say
I love you we how lucky we as Americans
get up [ __ ] make some notes do
whatever the [ __ ] you need to do
although we get lunchbox back understand
sometimes it takes time sometimes you
could do it on one day I'm gonna get so
stoned I have to take a little nappy-poo
little wake up the [ __ ] 8:30 or so
good morning Susan how are you this
morning
you know me the one jumping jacks ready
to go rethink your deal with him people
walking their dogs I'm chitchat with him
the sixth of the morning that's how to
do it you want to make it like better
you gotta get a barrel you gotta make a
[ __ ] plan
pitiful change fiance the early bird
gets the worm trust me when I'm [ __ ]
telling you
even when I was snorting [ __ ] kilos I
was up early with the [ __ ] rooster
making sure he was all right get him Sam
but joy was with the chit chatting of a
spark another ball
[ __ ] yeah we're going deep into American
wars you want to wake up listen you
wanna hang out my uncle Joey at 9:00
that's a different Uncle Joe oh do you
wanna hang out with Uncle Joe is 6:00
a.m. we go deep
oh [ __ ] there we go just like that
little boat with the family here and we
get that we leave the house and I'm the
[ __ ] more Derby's happy young man what
do you have to be sad about huh what do
you have to bender
I got depression but get the [ __ ] daddy
and this is the answer
put your little [ __ ] baseball hat on
with the propeller on and get out there
because if you don't somebody else will
but he don't know this is it this as
good as it gets people everything see
you gotta be on a yacht twist him by the
pool with a bunch of [ __ ] chicks that
can't smell don't add with nice tits
than him
you wake up in the morning nice after
you [ __ ] I'm gonna make a nice
having no smoothie I'm gonna be fired
until about 9:30 I got a couple calls I
got you Jude - today I got spiked
tonight they don't make dog I got
acupuncture I'm always trying to make it
happen I'm gonna have a stick some
needles suddenly some smoke comes out of
my [ __ ] ears and that's it what else
you what do you think happens here come
on you think people are full of sapphic
or get the [ __ ] yeah that's these
[ __ ] Gentiles we think they got
something to say [ __ ] I got to say you
know we have to say grab your cup smoke
a bowl and [ __ ] go live your [ __ ]
dream get all [ __ ] Twitter and
Facebook in your day who gives a [ __ ] go
live your [ __ ] you want stories go
live the [ __ ] life
get on the Greyhound bus the [ __ ]
for the Kansas's some meat some [ __ ]
real interesting people not these
[ __ ] people at the coffee shop
talking about friends who gives a [ __ ]
wasn't it
get on a [ __ ] bus call discover
America discover yourself
Columbus didn't know he could kill
people clean out on the boat you would
think what do you know yeah bring up
Columbus Joey what the [ __ ] yeah I'm
trying to have a positive [ __ ] day
anyway
as you know I'm totally Gibbs right then
I'm gonna go finish my coffee top this
nicotine gum and go talk to my [ __ ]
self in Tamil shams and I suggest you'd
do the same
got no podcast and I will be back
tomorrow but remember I told you get out
there get out there and live gets a [ __ ]
about this guy and that guy and uncle
joke is a [ __ ] get out there go [ __ ]
write some stories and then get back to
make that sucker I'll be checking in
with you this afternoon
just to make sure everybody's tip-top
condition and I'll show you the way they
got in the car at some [ __ ] week that
was groaning jubilant
I can't wait to smoke again I'm saying I
love you guys have a great day don't
take [ __ ] from nobody and [ __ ] em all
they all gotta suck you dick at the end
of the day boy or hear my dick don't
they called blicket I don't wanna like
wait that they were head did and thought
no palanca same colic goodness Lamar
they didn't give a month about being a
higher I love you guys